if you have a small local business you
probably shouldn't make General business
content why because there's massive
business tycoons that make content and
if I'm going to pick between two even if
it's the same content I'm going to
listen to the guy who has more
credibility and so you want to be
credible about whatever it is and so
what you do is you draw a smaller and
smaller Circle about what you're
credible about and that you can't be
questioned on so if you're Plumbing like
you're a plumber in a certain town you
can become king of that plumbing puddle
in that tiny little town and over time
you can expand your plumbing puddle to
the general local business Pond and then
the lake of brick and mortar chains and
so forth and then eventually the ocean
of General business so the idea is that
you take small steps outwards as you
gain more and more credibility